in our Network
world global challenges go beyond
National borders and national interests
we're in a difficult situation Russia's
brutal attack on Ukraine a China's
increasingly aggressive uh rise to power
gallium germanium and graphite are uh
already speaking a clear language so
let's express our uh Ric sovereignty
let's show that we can act effectively
just four months ago the commission put
forward a critical material a raw
materials
act another four months required for
trialogue one more month to uh have the
final vote here in Parliament this is
record-breaking uh fast work Europe is
showing that we can act rapidly and we
should do this more often in future I
think this is a good feasible practical
uh uh law which ensures a reliable
supply of critical raw materials for
Europe that will further the uh digital
and green Transitions and support our
economy it will help the economy rather
than burdening it burdening it it will
it simplify uh the permitting procedure
it will give uh planning security for
companies rather than more reporting
requirements many of the key points of
the parliament's position are included
I'll flag up four of them for you a new
Innovative concept with a recycling
Benchmark based upon the uh raw
materials are already available to us in
waste this is a a realistic approach
rather than looking at insecure
forecasts for consumption in 2030 what
we're talking about is the quantity of
those critical raw materials in waste
now and how much we can recycle so that
sends out a clear signal to the
recycling industry we want strategic raw
materials recycled in Europe second
Point ambitious and plannable permitting
procedures at the moment permitting
procedures for critical raw material uh
uh projects have a 15-year time window
on average time is
money we need to shorten these time
frames 15 months for processing projects
and recycling projects these kind of
ambitious time Fred will finally allow
planning sa security for companies in
Europe thirdly clear Central uh Partners
to speak to all too often different
bureaucratic offices dealing with
different issues was too complicated now
we ensure that there's a single uh
Authority that's responsible for the
permitting process and for the company
it's even better they always have one
Central interlocutor who is the
responsible for their project
thirdly then we have a burst for
Innovation along the value chain
strategic
project uh can be promoted through
that's one of the initiatives of this
Parliament we want to ensure that we can
scale up and uh promote Innovation this
will mean a reduction of the waste from
mining that's going to be important
every uh critical raw material that we
can reuse or avoid the use of is one
that we don't have to import this will
all allow us to be an attractive partner
for partners around the
world this will uh help us to deal with
economic and geopolitical risks and the
extraction industry the processing the
re Recycling and waste will create new
chances for our partners and for us so
we create planning security for
companies we create genuine incentives
for private investment in the EU with
reliable Partners in third countries we
secure jobs and uh Prosperity we reduce
dependency and we ensure ourselves
against the storms of geopolitics
whether they're coming from east or west
so I would like to thank the European
Council and the Spanish Council
presidency I'd also like to thank the
commissioner uh particularly
commissioner preton and his director
General and I'd like to thank everyone
responsible in the European Parliament
and your teams for this productive
future orientated negotiations and the
constructive work over the last few
months I'd particularly like to thank
the staff of the uh uh European
Parliament for ensuring that we could
get uh the process through so quickly
and I'm looking forward to an
interesting debate abing
than thank you very much for the
international trade
committee
Mrs
asop thank you very much in July China
said there would be a partial ban on
Experts of gallium and it accounts for a
large share of this in the world now
Rare Earth and magnesium actually 100%
of the eu's needs come from China
critical raw materials are key if we are
to move forward with the green
transition and the digital transition
batteries electrical cars wind turbines
and mobile phones they all need these
crms so this act will help us make sure
we have enough Supply and diminish the
dangerous dependence on one sole
supplier producing crms within the EU is
part of the solution Greece has the
possibility of producing a lot of
gallium which can account for part of
what the e EU needs the European
Parliament is sending out a clear
message today the EU is ready to tackle
the flaws and weaknesses in the supply
chain so the CRM act has to be supported
with new sources of funding now thank
you thank you now for the uh Envy
committee the next speaker is Mrs
pfad
thank you very much president uh
commissioner
colleagues today we are voting to
improve our access to raw materials in
the EU we're talking about minerals and
metals that we need for the green
transition and for our future economy so
this is an important decision we are
taking at the moment uh it's h very
difficult to extract these materials in
the EU so we are dependent on imports
from third
countries this is a risky situation
we've seen this previously with
geopolitical issues and protectionist
tendencies we can see around the world
so we have an opportunity to change this
with this
legislation and that would be uh very
important we uh need these minerals for
uh the transition and we are seeing uh
increased demand for these um minerals
in our green transition so it's time
that we act here uh mining uh once made
uh Sweden rich and it's something that
will help uh Europe on its future
Journey thank
you thank you very much I will now give
the floor to commissioner
Bron
mer uh thank you very much president
Madame raor
Nicola colleagues members I'd like to uh
salute the work done by the European
Parliament over the last few months on
the critical Ro materials act when we
made this proposal it was in
March we had a joint commitment to act
on critical raw materials to reduce our
dependency and to ensure that we could
have a a Ure and sustainable supply of
these U
materials we have made progress despite
our
differences at the outset we have been
able to uh get this through the
legislative process in record time and
we cover the whole of the value
chain we support the extraction
processing and recycling of critical raw
materials in Europe the whole
continent needs to understand the uh key
role of trade and international Partners
as well we need to improve the security
of Supply through this proposal whilst
also ensuring that environmental uh
standards are not only respected but
also reinforced we strengthen the EU uh
against the kinds of pressure that third
parties want to exert on
ponas and we're increasing our capacity
for industrial production in Europe so
that we can have a Europe that can be
the master of its own
destiny I could just like to welcome
certain uh elements from the parliament
here you have worked hard to reduce
administrative burdens to streamline
procedures because some of the
Declaration obligations are
inevitable some of the uh
rationalization has allowed for time
frames to be reduced particularly on
strategic projects and the Parliament
has also included en a realistic
objective for reducing
demand particularly taking into account
environmental risk and making
multipartite governance an important
part of the whole certification
system you have bolstered the ambition
of the regulation on sustainability
without reducing the impact of the
proposal for economic growth the
parliament has also insisted on the fact
that strategic Partnerships have to
bring local added value
and they have to strengthen social and
economic economic development in
developing countries too all of these
elements were included in the final deal
and they will help us to conclude future
strategic Partnerships thank you very
much for all of your work and I'd also
like to thank the Spanish and Swedish
presidencies of the council the critical
raw materials act will enter into Force
at the beginning of next year and it's
important that Europe should catch up uh
in the race for access to critical Raw
materal materials that's why yesterday
the uh commission started meetings with
uh industrial Partners in the critical
raw materials chain strategic projects
have to become reality on the ground so
I count upon the parliament to ensure
that the momentum is maintained and the
commitments of the member states to
support this European agenda are
followed up
on finally there will be a uh governance
Forum in the form of the critical raw
materials board
they will keep a look at stocks and
spread best practice particularly when
it comes to public procurement and
implementation of national uh extraction
programs and circularity the Parliament
will have an important role monitoring
this
legislation and you will have a scrutiny
role when it comes to the activities of
the board and the implementation of the
act as a whole the parliament's com uh
uh contribution has been terminant in
ensuring that this is an important piece
of legislation and I am convinced that
you will support this new regulation
thank you very much
you we still have two more speakers on
behalf of committees now on behalf of
the Foreign Affairs committee Miriam
lexman is
next thank you dear colleagues
commissioner let me thank colleagues
across this house for their cooperation
and Speedy conclusion of negotiations of
this file which reflects the urgent need
to implement its
Provisions in today's world geopolitical
context it is essential for the EU not
to be dependent on few suppliers
especially those which pose a security
threat to the union like the
totalitarian China I believe that
coordination and cooperation with our
allies and strategic partners are key to
successful implementation of this act
this is is why I initiated a joint
Declaration of legislators from around
the world to work together in ensuring
secure ethical and sustainable access to
critical raw materials which will be
published later
today in his context I also encourage
the
commission to conclude more such
Partnerships and to add a critical raw
materials component to existing and
future agreements with third countries
thank you than
you thank you very much now on behalf of
the development the regional development
committee rather France
bogovich commissioner president dear
colleagues also the regie
committee happily supports this basic
report and adds its opinion to it in it
in our opinion we support the basic
objectives to increase the extraction of
these minerals in Europe we also welcome
The increased capacity of processing and
Recycling and also the
diversification uh of Supply it is very
important that we ensure the speed of
citing of s such projects and also the
speed of Permitting procedures and it is
extremely important to well work
together with the local and Regional
communities without engaging local
communities these objectives will be
hard to achieve this is why we very much
want that all of those who want to site
and Implement such projects come to
local communities also ensure uh
additional infrastructure and this will
also provide new jobs in the environment
and this will be the best guarantee for
strategic projects to be successful in
the future Mr commissioner I hope that
you receive as many as uh strategic
projects as possible and that we achieve
strategic autonomy when it comes to raw
materials in
Europe so the next speaker are the eight
representatives of the political groups
we'll start with hild deard
benty commissioner pron ladies and
gentlemen we have an EU critical uh raw
materials act and we did this with a lot
of female
power we have uh made this at the center
of our EU industrial strategy and we've
sent out an important message by doing
this to the global economy that we as
the EU are going to be uh active in
maximizing our potential in dealing with
the need for raw materials in the future
for future Technologies and it will be
made in Europe that we will have new
stable relations with uh reliable
Partners so it will be a win-win
situation in our raw materials uh
relationships we will have real social
uh dialogue uh transparency uh
sustainability this is not just about
getting more and more it's about
improving
efficiency and uh systematically trying
to use waste or recycling or
substitutions we are sending a clear
message to uh investers and employers
for strategic projects um authorizations
will will be sped up so it'll be much
easier to uh manage the risks and it
will be better for banks to invest uh
companies will have more options for
cleaner and reliable raw materials
sources we need to manage this critical
raw materialist management but without
new uh bureaucracy when it comes to
processing mining recycling all of this
will be part of the green deal and will
create new job uh potential
we are putting in place the structures
for more efficiency future
digitalization protecting the
environment this new framework is going
to provide more security for our
citizens as well and we look forward to
working in the implementation of this
legislation thank
you thank you very much the next speaker
is Mr Muhammad
shahim yeah thank you very much
president
it's
straightforward the more
energy and green electricity we have and
the less coal the more lithium we're
going to need we also need a whole set
of materials for solar panels and
generators now these uh raw materials
can be found outside the
EU but I think that the EU also has to
examine closely where we can get these
raw materials and how we can better use
the ones that we do have in Europe
already now we need better Partnerships
with third
countries but we have to be on an equal
footing with our partner countries and
suppliers so we need a raw material
green transition as well we have to
improve manufactur ING with sustainable
technology I'd like to congratulate the
raor and the commission let us implement
this act properly thank you Madame
Marie a threat to our gallium Imports a
threat to our germanium Imports a threat
to our graphite Imports a threat to our
uh Rare Earth oxide Imports this will
damage Europe's economy we have to put
an end to this situation of dependency
through this uh critical raw materials
act we need to diversify our cooperation
we need to work together with our
partners to on on the route to carbon
neutrality that's what's special about
Europe that we can work together to
respond to Global challenges we can get
third countries on board and we can get
citizens on board to do that we need to
explain be
transparent we need to now debate the
implementation of these Partnerships in
practice Europe needs to emerge from its
state of dependency but it needs to
benefit everybody and this process needs
to be transparent that's what's special
about Europe that's what we have fought
for and that now must now become reality
thank you for Henri Han thank you very
much Henri Han is
next for our green deal we need critical
raw materials and Europe has delivered
extremely quickly we're diversifying our
supply chains this is going to be
important for industry and for small
businesses in Europe lithium and other
rare earth materials are extremely
important we're use them for solar
panels electric cars computer chips wind
turbines with this
legislation uh in 20123 we have in
record time reached a mile stone for um
mining these raw materials in
Europe we are working on uh reducing our
dependence on these uh critical
materials and looking at substitutions
with the crma we have Green Technology
made in Europe we have the possibility
to work on our strategic economy and not
have to worry about importing from
questionable countries such as Russia or
China we are building a raw materials
sector here in uh Europe we are building
strong Global Partnerships so we can be
competitive uh in the uh green economy
without negatively impacting our economy
the recycling uh Benchmark will now be
25 uh% of the annual uh consumption of
these strategic raw
materials we will be looking at um how
we can recycle these from waste in the
EU and this is extremely positive for
the recycling industry as well so that
that's very important for us as
greens our uh civil economy has to be uh
involved in mining in Europe as well and
uh
we have um a final text that refers to
the oecd uh text and guidelines which is
very important the final text also has a
recital against deep sea Mining and that
is in important we want that to remain a
taboo in the EU the European
parliament's mandate uh has protection
measures in that's
um
important we want to make sure that
there are uh no uh Provisions that are
um detrimental to the environment we
want this uh green transition we need
those critical raw materials so we need
to focus our Mining and our extraction
um and use the highest social
environmental criteria thank you CL
isella
Helena this clz is next
speaker thank you very much
president commissioner ladies and
gentlemen Poland produces two types of
raw materials that are extremely
important cing coal which is vital for
producing steel and copper and vital
also for semic conductors therefore and
cables after tricky but effective
negotiations and thank you very much for
them we managed to make sure that cing
Co was going was included on the list it
plays a very important role in the
European economy and this is recognized
by the European commission itself and
thank you very much commissioner Bron
for this uh the energy transition needs
steel copper and a lot of other critical
raw material
that we have to uh look for in the EU
first and foremost and we also have to
make sure that we look at our
technological uh capacity and what we
have here in the EU if we move too
quickly then we're encouraging uh
companies to relocate and this will
de-industrialized the EU the European
economy will not be appealing or
attractive and if ideology
is uh comes first and foremost then we
could have these
consequences now I think that there's a
lot of common sense here we also have to
think about the economic plan and the
forecast
uh J jashim bash through mine in Poland
plays an important role in manufacturing
coke and coal the miners in Cela play an
important
role thank you
president commissioner
colleagues well when you start building
a house you start with the foundations
and not with the roof and before we
start uh setting ambitious objectives we
have to ask ourselves have we got the
necessary tools at our disposal to
actually achieve those
objectives this is the eenth
confirmation that the uh trans green
transition has not been put together
with the highest degree of rationality
I would like to compliment the raor
however because she has conducted this
work with a good level of
speed you could actually say that her
initial remarks were a bit too
optimistic but nevertheless the text
that we'll be voting on in this plenary
is one that LGA will be
supporting but this text arrives too
late and in addition there's a lack of
sufficient
financing I think we need to have a look
at what other countries have been doing
such as the United Kingdom they have
also been working on critical raw
materials so the we are laying the first
bricks but we are playing catchup and
it's going to be a complicated process
thank
you Mrs Cornelia an is the next
speaker thank you very much the uh
commission uh proposal when we first saw
this caused Great concern to me and
other uh Civil Society actors it seemed
as if it was just a gift to Industry for
our group as for others we
uh needed to have um clearer guidelines
higher environmental standards better
respect of Human
Rights so we negotiated in the EP uh in
the EP sorry and uh work together with
the rapporter to get a new uh position
looking at the social and environmental
standards looking at uh free prior and
informed consent for indigenous uh
people and uh looking at Deep Sea mining
uh as well and the status of strategic
projects the uh trialogues always means
we have to um take a slightly different
perspective things that we have to think
again so the fpic for example so we have
mixed feelings uh
here we are pleased that there will be a
consultation uh with uh indigenous
people to try and minimize any kind of
uh damages but we would have preferred
to have a clear consent uh principle
formulated um more than 50% of the uh
raw materials are found in the
territories of uh indigenous people so
we have to bear in mind these social and
environmental standards it's hugely uh
important a lot has been uh done here
and I hope that the implementation will
live up to this thank
you uh next speaker is Mr
y thank you president thank you
commissioner a lot has been said on what
isn't quite a rare Earth's War but is at
least a critical raw materials race I
would like to highlight four key points
first of
all it's not about just about price
because this is more of a tug of war
it's about power we have to make sure
that the European nations set their
priorities and um use their clout on the
ground let us not allow ourselves with
to have our back up against the wall we
cannot just depend on one single country
or one region innovation has to help us
move towards substitution or
replacement Rare
Earth uh and fertile soil is uh
something rare as well let us not allow
ourselves to be trapped by geopolitical
interests that are not ours let us not
let conflicts and wars that aren't ours
trap us European interests must
Prevail Madame Maria DEA cavalo next is
Mrs cavalo the flooor is
yours
president president commissioner
colleagues external dependence for the
European Union on when it comes to
critical raw materials is an obstacle to
our future we need need to take
advantage of the resources that we have
available we have to reduce bureaucratic
barriers to mining activities and ensure
that that activity is responsible and
sustainable the critical raw materials
Act is a step in the right direction at
the same time though at the member state
level the important thing is that these
processes should be transparent and
should involve local authorities local
populations uh local companies and
associations in all decisions that are
taken in Portugal my own country
unfortunately the current government has
gone for a very opaque strategy to
towards lithium mining the consequences
are not hard to predict they have been
very negative
consequences we need to defend the
public
interest working together with the uh
general public thank you very much this
why
thank you very much next speaker is Mr
Yen
Gia president thank you very much uh
chair commissioner Bron dear
colleagues for our electric cars our
wind turbines our
computers a lot of our future
Technologies we are dependent on these
raw materials and we're dependent on
importing
them
and we saw uh we uh earth materials were
found in Sweden at the beginning of this
year so we need to continue looking for
these uh raw materials and it's uh good
um that we have uh better
authorizations uh now uh but we need to
have higher environmental uh standards
in this area recycling is sustainable
it's important we have a 20 5% uh Target
now and I am pleased uh that we uh have
that uh it's going to be important in
German Germany and North AR faia where
we have uh a lot of work in this area we
also have uh substitution uh products uh
lithium being substituted uh for example
um if we uh do this we can uh reduce the
power power of dictators and that will
be positive for the world thank you very
much our next speaker is Karen
kortman president commissioner
colleagues in Europe we consume about a
quarter of the world's raw
materials but we only produce 3% ourself
so we are largely dependent on Imports
primarily from China trade creates
Prosperity but that can be at a
price for the climate we need
electrification and that requires huge
quantities of critical raw
materials in Sweden and other parts of
Europe there are huge reserves
underground but we do not take advantage
of them as we should now that Russia is
turning off the gas TS Taps and China is
uh reducing its supply of critical raw
materials so not producing is a bad
idea we cannot extract these materials
at the expense of indigenous peoples or
the
environment we are voting for a plan to
increase the recycling of critical raw
materials in Europe and I think that
that
shows that we need to unite to for
better
sustainability m
the floor is yours thank you next
speaker is s
mat thank you very
much the issue of critical raw materials
is vital for our electric cars and other
products uh demand has skyrocketed and
that is why the more renewable energy we
want the more critical raw materials we
need
we have to look at how we can work in a
smarter way and how we can recover
certain Ro
materials we need to ride our bikes more
we need to use electric cars more we
need of course a certain amount of
fossil fuels but we have
to introduce rules to curtail the use of
certain materials we need to reduce our
need for energy because in this way
we'll be able to reduce our dependence
on uh authoritarian
regimes and will be able to promote
circular economy and that will benefit
our pockets it will be good for the
economy and for everyone thank
[Music]
you Mr niss has the floor
next thank you very much uh chair the
the moment we have a Chinese Monopoly
for our critical raw materials that we
need for electric cars solar panels and
wind uh turbines previously we were
dependent on Russian gas and now we are
dependent on China so we're just
swapping one dictatorship for
another
we should not uh forget that uh China
can easily increase materials uh when
they uh want we don't want to get C in a
political power play here so we need to
do everything we can to reduce our uh
dependence so it's important that we
open up new Swedish mines but that's not
going to uh be enough uh the mines we
open aren't going to end our uh
dependence it's um a dream to be um 100%
uh
renewable uh thank you thank Madame Mar
toi
the floor next is mar
DOI ladies and gentlemen we're here to
vote on a proposal for regulation on
critical raw materials after
negotiations with other
institutions finally you recognize your
mistakes for years we've been condemning
your Ultra liberal policy that led to
unfair competition and made us dependent
on uh raw materials that are key for
industry but finally you've woken up
better late than never even though it
took you way too long you're finally
admitting that countries should be able
to fund forward looking projects uh to
compete against our International Rivals
you want to reduce our dependence by
setting partial autonomy targets and
limiting partially limiting uh imports
from third countries you finally
recognize the fact that we will not
tolerate importing uh materials that uh
do not respect human rights and
environmental standards this shows once
again uh the failure of the EU better
late than never but how much time have
we lost because of the fact that you
remained inactive thank you maren B next
is Marin
B
thank thank you very
much well probably we'll be seeing more
mining in the in the near future we need
these Min minerals and materials for our
cars for our uh uh wind turbines
Etc but it's very important that this
mining should take place in an econ
ecologically and socially sustainable
manner we have to mine in a manner that
respects the environment we have to do
so while protecting indigenous people's
rights we have to do
it so that we do not deplete the the
soil too much and so I have tried to
ensure that this legislation takes into
account all of these that we have
environmental assessments we protect uh
indigenous people's rights the Sami in
Finland and Sweden in particular and we
should now already be taking the steps
needed to reduce demand for these
materials so that we also reduce our
energy uh demand at the same time these
are steps that we have to
take to
accompany our uh steps to uh mine more
unfortunately my own government has
worked hard to undermine indigenous
people's rights they are undermining the
work that's been done in the parliament
we need to ensure
that this legislation uh should have
demands I don't think the current
legislation lives up to the uh
requirement if we are to have socially
economically and environmental
sustainable mining it has to be socially
and environmentally uh sound and based
on Democratic
decision-making cathalina ralova is
next thank you very
much
president I think this legislation is
very important
we need to uh be responsible to our
citizens when it comes to deciding where
this mining will take place we know that
these raw materials are very important
for our different
Technologies I am
pleased that we will be looking at
recycling
more we want to support recycling in the
future we don't want to be just sending
our waste to Africa so we need to look
at Mining and extraction in Europe I
think that's very important our
production uh capacity our processing
should be
increased our policy of colonialism
should uh be limited and we should uh
concentrate on what we have available to
us I think the 40% Target for us in
Europe is very
good pres thank you very
much
digital Technologies as we know play a
decisive role in promoting Innovation
and competitiveness in industry and no
one doubts that to uh fully developed
digital Technologies we need critical
raw
materials thanks to the European
Parliament uh the agreement with the
council
includes uh uh permit procedure es that
are faster better recycling
policies uh better waste management and
a list of critical raw materials uh
including aluminium and
graphite that play a very important role
in the value chain is the European
parliament's contribution to the whole
process and we must be very pleased with
this International Partnerships with
third countries that are trustworthy
play a key role this is been mentioned
before these third parties or third
countries are more stable and more
reliable we have to pay particular
attention to EU funded projects in a
nutshell in order to boost the
competitiveness of the EU industry on
the global stage and in order to
consolidate our strategic autonomy and
sovereignty the CRM a plays a very
important role it's also a tangible
example of the added value provided by
the European Union thank
you Gales
M now miss Lina Gales Munoz thank you
very much president chair
congratulations to the negotiating team
and to the Spanish presidency this is a
very important agreement that puts in
place the basis for our strategic
autonomy and guarantees access to
critical raw materials for European in
reindustrialization and the necessary
green and digital transition it means
the creation of quality jobs it means um
we can help put people in areas at risk
of
depopulation we have a target of 4% for
processing and uh refining a recycling
Target of 25% of annual consumption by
2030 there is also um an increase in
what has to be recovered from waste um
that is is also important there is a
greater environmental sustainability
guarantee more economic sustainability
it is a more balanced uh relationships
with our social partners and there will
be more research to uh discover new raw
materials we have to bear in mind uh the
impact that mining has on certain areas
we have to make sure that citizens are
fully involved and participate in the
benefits and profits here as well so we
need to invest in uh training uh and
teaching uh skills ensuring quality jobs
uh there are 17 critical materials
identified in andalia so we will be
closely uh following the implementation
of this we want to make sure this brings
wellbe to the citizens more strategic
autonomy and uh High environmental and
social standards thank you very much
thank
you Mr dagaki is
next thank you chair dear commissioner
Bron dear colleagues the critical raw
materials Act is a clear statement of
intent we want the EU to be a Visionary
and astute geopolitical actor with the
tools to match that
ambition besides the important trade and
environmental aspects that this
agreement covers we are stepping up the
game in strengthening our resilience and
fostering our priorities in a divid in a
divided world with many challenges to
come with this act we are creating the
right conditions sourcing the right
materials for achieving the green and
digital transition
objectives by boosting Investments and
encouraging Innovation within the union
and Beyond its borders we reduce
dependencies so that we can remain
competitive without renouncing our
values refusing to be economically and
politically CED I think this is one of
the major achievements of this
legislature and I want to congratulate
the reporter and the shadows for the
work done in this file thank
you thank you Madame Rose Carolina the
floor is yours Caroline Rosa is
next thank you very much president the
green transition is going to require
huge quantities of critical raw
materials we need to ensure that the EU
can uh get its supplies from its own
territory uh particularly given the
challenges faced at the social
environmental and human level we have to
ensure that this mining activity takes
place within planetary boundaries
the commission has put forward
interesting proposals on circularity and
recycling but they hav't really put
forward a uh less wasteful model and
they haven't uh questioned the issue of
making everything
digital unfortunately this is an
extractivist logic that is being pursued
here the right of indigenous peoples and
local populations have to be respected
including the prior uh consent principle
and that should be uh informed consent
we cannot continue to endanger nature
through our mining activities but in
this legislation member states reserve
the right to carry out extractive
activities in protected areas and uh to
uh Place public interest uh uh criteria
on top of those we have to be very
Vigilant Mr toski is
next
president commissioner ladies and
gentlemen everything that we have done
to achieve this text is extremely
important and the timing is perfect
because we want to Breathe new life into
the process of uh uh extracting uh new
critical raw materials and processing
them we have to focus on Recycling and
support re research and development so
that we can have sound management of raw
materials and their
substitutes uh this act includes very
important points I'd like to draw your
attention to an aspect which is linked
to increasing the extraction of raw
materials in Europe will we be able will
we be able to do this while we are
actually destroying the extractive
industry in the
EU we are trying to systematically
eliminate mines in Europe that is our
policy and that flies in the face of the
provisions in this
act it could be that in a few years time
we won't have the facilities or the
equipment or the uh mining companies
necessary and will become dependent on
raw materials from third
countries thank you very much Marcus
bite is
next thank you very much president
ladies and uh gentlemen
you
uh uh can see that we have in a very
difficult situation with critical raw
materials and this was uh
predictable uh but we're uh still uh
flailing around as we were in the past
and the uh causes for this are issues
with uh ideology that we've concluded in
our trade agreements in the past we
should uh be honest uh to uh industry
employeers workers and say that here in
this Parliament uh before as now we are
putting ideology before industry thank
you very much and what is here
migueles next is Miguel
uban
gra thank you very much president the
truth is that there is a global race to
control raw materials against the
backdrop of an ecological
emergency now the green transition is
being called into question leading to uh
mining fever around the world uh all we
talk about is the green deal but to
manufacture electric cars in Europe we
need more mining in the global South and
here in Europe raw materials not only
for a green transition but also to to uh
fuel the arms race this is a capital uh
green capitalism that is Tainted with
blood because this is polluting uh soil
and it is also expelling those who live
on this land but there is more and more
resistance that want to fight against
this mining fever such as the Ecuador uh
mining front which we greet from here uh
we don't want a new neoc colonialist
mining wave we want to consume less and
distribute more green capitalism is not
okay there is an um a climate emergency
at the moment thank you is Madame maet
pakas next is maet
pakas President commissioner
colleagues well I'd love to say to you
that the proposal for uh
uh proposed legislation is better than
uh what was put forward
originally but actually the a lot of the
objectives have been reduced because
it's no point uh implementing things
that are just not feasible in
practice what do citizens expect of the
European Union they expect a good Europe
a Europe that tries to find solutions
for our future Industries and to support
major projects of Collective public
interest so we we should have no shame
in acting in line with our interests
without ideology we should support our
mining industry on the uh European
Mainland but also in uh the uh outermost
region like newel
caladon we need to
ensure that environmental and social
rules are respected thank you very much
SAR the and next is
SAR thank you very much uh chairman
critical raw materials are key
ingredients when it comes to our green
transition without that we're not going
to um manage the electrification of our
transporter and our industrial
sectors previously we have these uh
critical materials from uh China Africa
uh Asia we have to think about if we're
going to increase our dependence or look
for these in Europe the European
parliament's position when it came to
negotiating the critical raw materials
act uh includes important points such as
uh fror and uh uh free and prior
informed consent the F pick uh this is
uh important because otherwise um we
have the potential consequences of uh
indigenous people uh vetoing uh these uh
mining we have uh in Europe the Sami
people who live in a lot of these areas
where these minerals uh exist uh that
are important for the uh
transition so um we no longer have the
veto right in this
legislation
we have uh a lot of uh steps that are uh
taken in the uh wrong uh direction we
have to make sure we're uh not hampering
European industry with this thank you
frina penov the Flor Miss penov is the
next
speaker chair commissioner Bron dear
colleagues all the Technologies uh we
will need to reach our uh climate
ambitious goals we require huge
quantities of raw materials electric
cars solar panels batteries ITC
Technologies and more have a great G
need for the critical raw materials we
need strategic Partnerships with third
countries to be able to diversify and
Ure a stable supply of those materials
we have to refine them in the EU and
produce the final products here
ourselves and this can only happen by
cutting red tape boosting Innovation and
developing alternative ways of
production enhancing circularity
ambitious recycling uh targets are
crucial to achieve the Net Zero
production levels here in the EU this
legislation sets the right economic
incentives for a more stable secure
sustainable and socially responsible
models for the deployment of Mining and
recycling projects of course that
includes also the faster permitting
procedures we cannot build a new green
economy without ensuring the existence
of the necessary resources thank you
thank
you here erugu the floor is yours Mr
erugu is the next speaker
president commissioner today we're
voting on legislation which is good for
the European Union because it makes us
independent from Imports or at least
less dependent on Imports of critical
raw materials I am convinced that this
law is a step in the right direction I'd
like to congratulate all of the uh
people who've worked on it especially
Nicola bear you've worked on this at a
pretty impressive pace and shown that
the European Union is capable of acting
rapidly the EU will always be dependent
on critical raw
materials but it's good that we have
less bureaucracy and we make it easier
to extract these resources in the EU I
think we send out a good signal as well
with uh the recycling
targets we have to become less dependent
on third countries we need raw materials
for our industry because we want to
remain an industrialized continent
that is the position of our political
family and that's why this law is so
important thank
[Applause]
you
n Mr
n Mr chair the European Union with this
legislative proposal is opening a fast
track to the mining uh project by
defining
mining as a
strategic project the commission can
guide a member State into a direction in
which ecological protection will be
dismantled and this is a wrong direction
we cannot carry out the green transition
in which is carried out at the cost of
environmental Targets in which countries
like Finland
already uh have about 70% of its nature
destroyed according to the uh nature
panel the fins can say to the swedes or
fins can say to swedes can say to the
fins that well your nature can be uh
destroyed because we need raw materials
and in this respect the Sami people's
position is very critical that's why the
greens are critical about the in the
legis legislative proposal even if
Parliament has improved it already but
we will vote against
it madame get it
done um microphone for the
speaker in Sweden and Finland there are
a lot of critical raw materials under
the ground we need that for the green
transition I'm a bit surprised when I
hear a Finnish member from The Finnish
green party saying that they want to
give the Sami a The veto right for
project so how are we going to have a
green transition at
all if we uh get these substances from
China and Africa instead the floor is
yours
um well thank you for the question the
you you will be aware that we do need to
be able to open new mines in Finland and
Sweden but it has to have happen in
cooperation with strict environmental
requirements you can't simply forget
Environmental Protections and uh the
rights of the
Sami we need to have better use of the
resources in the first place better
recycling rather than trying to Simply
create more environmental problems in
our natural
environment there were environmental
problems already before this legislation
it's only going to get worse Flor is
yours thank you very
much now colleagues talk about the
imperious need of getting our hands on
critical raw materials saying that it's
vital for our company's competitiveness
and so that we can depend Less on China
and the rest of the world it is V itle
to make sure we have strategic autonomy
we live in a world where are trying we
are trying to reduce uh
globalization we have uh ties with China
and the United States and we know that
we want to reduce our dependence on
China that now has a dominant position
so welcome to the critical raw materials
Club I think
that this is a landmark act we need an
agreement on critical raw materials with
the United States as well so that we can
better uh produce critical raw materials
for electric batteries thank
you the next
speaker thank you president colleagues
it is always a good idea to try and be
dependent this goes for many different
sectors but particularly for raw
materials however I'm not sure that this
act is going to get us
there uh will we really make ourselves
independent from Chinese uh raw uh
materials because we have been uh
dismantling uh mining in Europe for
decades uh so uh Independence doesn't
mean moving from China to other third uh
countries we've seen the problems we've
had uh with uh Russia because we get
that via third countries
now the EU uh hasn't dealt with getting
these uh energy sources properly whereas
uh China has been looking at these uh
markets and getting on top of
this so they have been uh quicker than
us and I think we have missed a moment
thank you Mara next speaker is Marisa
Matias thank you very much president
lithium literally moves mountains and in
Portugal's case it actually knocks them
down so we need to show vigilance and
scrutiny when it comes to how we Supply
ourselves with critical raw materials we
will never be able to do enough to
ensure that the public interest is
generally respected we need to ensure
that the economic interests of the few
does not uh Prevail over the general
public
interest the government in Portugal is
creating privileged regimes which damage
local populations in the environment
there are legal
subes which uh push the P Planet Beyond
its limits and do not respect human
rights this is not the path that we can
afford to take thank you markella the
Flor is Mark tabella is the next
speaker smart smartphones solar
panels uh these are examples of where we
need critical raw materials they're part
of our everyday life lithium and Cobalt
are crucial uh from a geopolitical point
of view and the crisis that we're
experiencing just increasing their
importance we have to make sure the EU
reduces its dependence on third
countries and looks at its Supply chains
and then measures and cooperating with
third countries the is this has to
respect uh fundamental rights and more
specifically workers rights we have to
respect local communities and the
environment this is an opportunity to H
come up with a
European um strategic Vision that will
also include the principle of due
diligence that we have supported uh here
with great uh enthusiasm thank you buy
the floor is yours Mr Bush much
president dear colleagues dear
commissioner sh I want to congratulate
and to thank commissioner Breton and
also our reporter and the negotiating
team for the quick constructive and
successful negotiation several uh
legislative proposal was high on the
agenda this autumn in the remit of
industry but but the proposal related to
critical raw materials Act is one of the
most important and I Amad to see its
final adoption the ACT will ensure will
ensure the supply of critical raw
materials for strategic industry sectors
and thereby contribute to the Union's
strategic goals green deal
digitalization but also industrial
independence by mitigating the risks for
Supply chains and ultimately enhance the
Union's economic resilience one of the
most efficient way to strengthen
European industrial resilience and
reduce dependencies is to diversify
supply chain and invest into research I
Echo that further support measures
should be put in place to support
research and Innovation for material
substitutions including sustainable
supplies in trade agreements and two
strategic Partnerships for raw materials
I believe it is important that the
critical raw material act will establish
lists of strategic raw materials and
critical raw materials based on their
economic importance and Supply risk and
will Implement faster permitting as
regulat
it is our privilege and duty to improve
the resilience of the union and the
field of industry is one that we should
further improve as it is at the core of
the economic and should be prosperous to
support our European way of life thank
you so
much the next speaker is
carlinho President commissioner ensuring
a secure supply of critical raw
materials is a a fundamental
precondition if the EU is going to
achieve open strategic autonomy it's
important if we are to be a global
leader in a multi-polar multilateral
world consolidating our independence
which is a precondition for uh healthy
interdependence I'm pleased to see
there's a broad consensus in the
committee on the fundamental principles
here that's to say focus on research and
Innovation to find new materials and
more sustainable processes so that we
can be more competitive and reduce
pressure on resources there's also
integrated monitoring of the supply
change ensuring that recycling is given
a better role there's also improvements
to the uh permitting processes and
better Partnerships with third countries
trying to ensure that we uh have active
cooperation and effective use of the
resource we need to ensure that we do
not engage in mining projects that do
not show necessary due diligence it's
good for the economy it's good for the
environment and it's good for people
thank you very
much the floor is
yours thank you very much president
commission we need lithium for batteries
and if we don't have rare earth
materials we don't have wind turbines or
electric cars China uses this as a
geopolitical weapon as Russia does with
oil and gas so if we have security of
Supply we will not have strategic
autonomy or our green transition so this
law that was pushed to you very quickly
is very welcome we need alliances with
reliable Partners such as Chile we also
need to accelerate uh the issuing of
permits but this is not uh sufficient in
uh Spain we have lithium and other rare
earth materials but it is difficult to
mine because there is social opposition
to these projects it is not sufficient
just to have high uh environmental and
sustainability guarantees we have to
make sure that the local uh communities
are fully involved in these uh strategic
uh project um that there's real added
value and quality jobs in these areas
and as we have also called for we need
more efforts made when it comes uh to uh
recycling waste and recovering these
materials thank
you Mr gal is next the next speaker uh
Mr
president commissioner good morning to
you
colleagues we are getting the critical
raw materials act on its way I pre would
have preferred if it was called The
Heavy Metal law I think that would be
more accessible to Europe citizens but
have we rocked it the scene well not so
sure about that yes okay we have taken a
step in the right direction but when I
was standing on the edge of the biggest
copper mine in Africa in Cales which
I've already reported back to you on you
can see the kind of environmental
consequences of
mining we don't see these kinds of Minds
in Europe so why are the commission the
conservatives trying to avoid having
International standards uh such as free
and prior informed consent that's a un
standard that we could have just simply
copy pasted into our legislation but
rather we vaguely sort of mention
something of the sort
and of course we need a veto right for
affected communities in mining regions
because at the end of the day they are
the ones who have to give their consent
if we don't make a sufficiently
attractive offer to them that's our
problem and we have to come back to them
with a better offer so it is an
improvement but there's still a lot of
space for improvement
there Mr President the commissioner uh
today we address the critical raw
materials act a vital Initiative for
Europe's industry and economic
Prosperity our Innovation Le continent
has up to now been overly reliant on
external sources for materials essential
to technology Technologies like chips
electric vehicle batteries or Renewable
Energy Systems I believe this act will
create a new Dynamic reducing our
dependency on Imports that pose risks to
our Economic Security and increasing
European Ambitions especially in the
digital sphere from the internal Market
perspective I welcome the new Provisions
regarding large companies that will now
assesses risks in their supply of Kyo
materials aiming to prevent any
disruptions in Supply chains that could
affect consumers I am confident that by
making rules clearer for companies and
reducing existing burdens we can
significantly boost business growth part
particularly in sectors crucial to our
technological and economic development
thank
you thank you m
Mato Mato adol is the next
speaker good morning president the text
we're discussing this morning aims to
reduce dependence on China both when it
comes to extraction and processing of
iCal raw materials that are vital for
energy transition for our energy
transition and for medical and
electronic equipment the EU strategy
wants to improve the extractive capacity
and processing in the EU and also to
diversify its Partners its trading
partners the CRM Act is also about more
investment in research and
innovation in this way it will protect
the environment by promoting circular
economy Recycling and higher
sustainability the agreement that we
reached finally is a starting point to
achieve
self-sufficiency and so that the EU will
have a circular economy it will Breathe
new life into the European economy will
guarantee new jobs over the next 5 Years
thank you
Madame next speaker is Mrs P Vice
if something has to happen quickly in
the EU it can and we need to act quickly
because we need to get away from the
dependency where we can only buy
critical raw materials in the global
market from much too few suppliers so
the green transition means that we need
to get more out of our own uh soil
otherwise we won't reach our climate
Target instead of buying it so the de
Industrial ization of the European
economy will not become the Innovative
growth we need not only for climate
goals but also for all we need in
defense area in Social and lab Sciences
so dear
colleagues thank you to the commission
and Council for the excellent
cooperation we've had about the new
critical raw materials
act and there's lot to follow up on and
facilitate because there's many
conflicts lying hidden in the
implementation of this we're talking
about the critical raw materials but
it's especially in the processing of
them that we will have
problems regardless of whether we mine
them for the first time or recycle them
in a circular economy it needs to be
done efficiently and without overlooking
the need for research and innovation in
substitute raw materials China is 10
years ahead of everyone else and it says
something about the need we have for the
speed in our Innovation there's no way
around it get
going thank you very much the next
speaker is Mrs
yakovich thank you Mr President Mr
Breton colleagues our economies cannot
function without secure transparent and
sustainable critical materials therefore
this is of the utmost importance for the
future of our European family uh this
week in the European Parliament we are
reacting to the aggressive uh Trade
Practices of China and Russia we are
reducing our dependence on critical
materials from third countries and if we
want to realize our goals of the green
de deal we have to secure um our uh raw
materials uh value chains and need to be
better when it comes to recycling by
adopting this act We Are One Step nearer
to strategic autonomy of the European
Union and to securing and strengthening
our position in the coming geopolitical
tension thank
you
Mrs M is
next chair commissioner
colleagues I would like to congratulate
the
rapor for the effective uh and efficient
work I want to thank the entire team
that worked on this file the agreement
reached with the council and the
commission contains sever several very
important elements I would like to
highlight in this final debate first um
it
encourages the refining uh the recycling
the substitution within Europe which is
extremely important for our policies the
administrative burden is being reduced
for companies uh working in this area
takes into account the need for
financial incentives for uh
pure uh Technologies for critical raw
materials also offers a framework for
strategic Frameworks with third
countries for strategic raw
materials thank
you thank
youle colle Alexandra thank you
Alexandra VRA is the next
speaker ladies and gentlemen the
proposed Sierra
CRM act
um uh should uh have our attention if we
want to give a chance to the green deal
so I'm going to vote in favor however
allow me to make a few comments uh when
you build a house you do not start with
the roof so when you propose a
legislative act it should have its logic
we have needed this act uh quite a long
time before when we adopted the battery
proposal at that time we realized that
we are going to face a lot of troubles
secondly it is uh very good that we do
not want to switch from one dependency
on fossile flues to another dependency
however to be prescriptive about targets
for
2013 that reminds me of theoretical
economic uh exercises that we used to
have under the Communist
Regime however what is important now is
that we are going to have accelerated
permitting procedures and hopefully uh
people uh who live at the extraction
site are going to understand
this thank you very much good morning
colleagues the next speaker is Alexandro
pansa commissioner well better late than
never
one of the few Common Sense proposals
from this commission mandate has arrived
right at the end of a legislative period
that has been full of
ideology maybe you could have got down
to these Common Sense proposals a bit
earlier with dealing with the green
transition we need the technology and
the materials in place first but instead
you started the wrong way
around cars agriculture mining we now
suddenly realize that to achieve the
objectives we've set we need the
resources you try to build our house but
you haven't ask whether you've got the
bricks to build it Europe depends on
third countries to import all of the
rare raw materials that needed for the
green transition and
electrification most of the our Imports
come from outside the eu's uh countries
but not even the eu's alliances so I
think you don't need to be a scientist
to realize that critical raw materials
are our weak point that we are dependent
on China so that's why this is a good
proposal it's a pragmatic approach it's
concrete it's uh very aware of reality
and I I think that finally there's a a
chance to abandon all of the Utopias
that have been indulged in in previous
years thank you very much the next
speaker is Martin
Kemp
pres commissioner president colleagues
our transition to climate uh neutrality
means we need to act accordingly when it
comes to our critical materials it is
necessary for environmentally friendly
Technologies and
digitalization if we want to see
technological progress and use our
resources uh sensibly we need to look at
the entire supply
chain and we uh need to really look at
how we use our critical raw materials we
need to use them in a sensible way we
need to look at the uh circular economy
uh repair Reuse
Recycling and um hopefully we can
improve our use of critical ra materials
in this uh way there needs to be an
attractive alternative for uh companies
so we need to see more Innovation and
research so we can uh really value these
uh better in a environmental uh social
economic way
and we need to be able to uh guarantee
our supply of critical raw uh materials
we need to be careful about our
dependence on third countries so we need
to diversify we need to ensure we have
secure uh Supply chains we need to build
that up and we need to strengthen the
sovereignty of the EU as well we need to
look together to find Solutions we need
to find trustworthy and reliable
partners and use our critical raw
materials in a sustainable way and to do
this we need to think in an Innovative
way so thank you very much to the
rapporter and to the
Shadows thank you very much the next
speaker is Lucas
kohut
without the silesian industry without
jobs in Silesia there won't be this
transformation in Europe and without
Coke and Co we won't be able to get
steel necessary for wind turbines and
Railways thanks to the work of the
20,000 miners in the mine inide Leia we
can uh um produce cing coal millions of
tons of cing coal which uh fulfills the
needs of the EU cing coal is on the list
of the CRM act uh this makes sense for
Poland for the European
Union uh because this will also help the
wind
turbines uh which draw
on cooking coal from cesia uh Poland is
one of the countries with the highest
with the highest number of raw materials
necessary it's thanks to Industry in
Silesia that we will have clean energy
thank you I think that was a point of
order or blue card blue card
got a blue card
please colleague you
have explained how much polish coold
stands at the
center of our future my question is for
how long do you think should we stick to
the coal approach that you are
advocating 10 years 20 years 50
years I will speaking polish if you
don't mind
trans now on
energy and the extraction of cing coal
in Silesia there's an agreement between
the trade unions on the one hand that
negotiated this agreement with the
Polish
government and this is up to 2049 for
coking coal it's a little bit different
because as I said coking coal is a
critical raw material to be able to
produce steel so we need to use this
cing Co it's better to use cing coal
from Silesia than cing coal imported
from
China thank you very much next speaker
is Nicola
Dante thank you very much president
commissioner
well in the wake of the pandemic the war
in Ukraine and the green transition now
we Face strategic vulnerabilities there
are critical raw materials that we need
for solar panels wind turbines batteries
etc etc so that's why today's vote is an
important building block in creating a
capacity for extraction and processing
in Europe whilst also ensuring higher
rates of recycling and reinforcing our
strategic autonomy but to be Freer we
will also need to be more active at the
global level we need to
diversify uh sources through trade
agreements with countries and other
continents we need to get Beyond a
mercantilist approach we need to work
together with the south of the world we
need to offer cooperation to Africa and
South America colleagues faced with
climate
change we cannot respond like the uh
right by uh denying the existence of
problems everyone anyone who thinks that
a small state can deal with the
challenges of the future without relying
on multilateralism and Global
cooperation is absolutely wrong they are
indispensable to overcome the problems
we
face thank you very much I'll now give
the floor to Alex agus
Sala
causing shortages of raw materials and
making Europe realize that strategic raw
materials are critical to achieve our
environmental and climate objectives and
digital transitions unfortunately in the
last few decades we have become overly
dependent or more than dependent on
third countries for the extraction of
critical raw materials needed to
accomplish the green and digital
transition in the current geopolitical
environment this constitutes an
unacceptable strategic vulnerability
digital Technologies and technological
sovereignity will require access to
strategic raw materials which are key
for some strategic Technologies and are
vulnerable to shortages we agly need to
tackle the increase in demand from
critical raw materials by supporting
resilient and diversified Supply chains
to meet current and future demand for
for critical raw materials in the EU we
also need to support the promotion of
the development and deployment of
substitute raw materials and measures to
ensure the eu's access to a secure and
sustainable supply of critical raw
materials thank
you thank you very much nles fugang is
next thank you dear colleagues dear
commissioner for too long we've been
naively believing in globalization
without asking critical questions we
thought we could uh get the goods that
we needed from wherever we needed uh it
didn't matter who we became dependent on
uh as long as we could make a good deal
in the meantime China has has
accelerated its industrial
transformation and has monopolized a lot
of the critical raw materials that we
need and we are indeed very dependent on
China today in fact 98% of the rare
earth that we need for our digital and
uh green economy comes from China
they're being processed in China and 60%
of global lith lithium is being
processed in China so today we are
dependent on a regime with whom we don't
share values it's about time we exit
this situation I think this act the
critical raw materials Act is a good
step in the right direction I may
especially happy to see The Benchmark of
recycling of raw materials of 25% by
2030 and that Europe should process 40%
of its annual needs of raw material
itself in
2013 let's get rid of the dependency
let's do it now thank
you thank you very much the next speaker
is Maria
graini speaker commissioner dear
colleagues I don't think there's any
doubt in anyone's mind that we need to
have uh critical raw materials in the
European union we need our own
production and to no longer depend on
third countries we need critical raw
materials for agriculture Health Care
construction and even for defense
commissioner in addition to the growth
in demand we have a problem with
Specialists we don't have enough
experts uh by 2030 we need
1,200,000 people experts in the in the
field of electromobility
and we also need to urgently act uh so
that we create a value chain here in the
European Union and this regulation will
certainly help with the
reindustrialization strategy we need to
improve Recycling and to know longer
directly or indirectly depend on third
countries we shouldn't criticize third
countries for producing we should
produce ourselves so I'm very grateful
for this critical raw material committee
that has just been set up uh but I also
wish that the European Parliament was a
member of this committee I understand
that it's a subgroup that focuses on the
involvement of smmes but I don't want to
repeat the mistakes we made in the
procurement directive we have to involve
uh smmes directly thank
you thank you very much the next speaker
is ail
varti thank you very much president
critical raw
materials represent the components for a
lot of uh components for the green
transition our dependence on these
resources has to be offset by the true
understanding of the social
environmental impact linked to
extraction and production both on our
continent and especially uh in countries
outside the EU that are the main
producers given this backdrop the
trialogue agreement lays down measures
to make sure we have a sustainable use
of these raw materials and promoting new
sustainable
technology we have to increase reuse and
Recycling and that is one of the pillars
of the national circular economy plans
to boost economic growth but at the same
time protect our planet so this act
gives us the possibility of
strengthening the Strategic strategic
autonomy of our continent and moving
towards uh uh n zero economy by 2050 but
commissioner we have to make sure that
we avoid environmental and social
disasters in Minds outside the EU thank
you thank you very much we come now to
the catdi procedure we have three
requests I give the floor to them all
starting by uh Anna
virun you got the floor
thank you Mr chair thank you to all the
negotiators for an excellent result and
a very Speedy processing I think that
this initiative regarding the critical
raw materials as one of the most
important ones of this legislation the
European Union must not be dependent in
any critical sector on any Third Country
it is important to increase the
production of critical raw materials in
Europe also their processing and their
recycling it would be a responsible to
promote the green transition and then
externalize all it all its fallbacks
outside Europe we know that both from
the point of view of environment and and
social rights and work we can act in a
responsible way and recycle it is also
important to invest in product uh
product uh development and we have to
create new subsid products and we have
to create uh new uh new
uh agreements with three third countries
so that we thank you very much mck
Wallace is next so the president the
transition to Renewables will require a
massive increase in levels of extraction
well we can significantly limit that
increase by reducing absolute resource
consumption
the parliament's 2021 report on the
circular economy Action Plan called on
the commission to propose targets to
significantly reduce the eu's material
and consumption Footprints by 2030 and
bring them within planetary boundaries
by 2050 that was three years ago and
still the commission has not acted
instead with the critical raw materials
act the EU is preparing to write a blank
check for the mining and arms Industries
while pretending this is climate action
aluminium and titanium have been added
to the list of critical raw materials
these minerals have very little to do
with the energy transition but they are
crucial for the arms industry an F22 Ste
bomber contains 39% titanium the
critical raw materials act will not make
our economy Greener but will certainly
make a fortune for the arms
industry thank you very much now I give
the floor to Chan
Kelly
Mar R critical raw materials mean
exactly that if it's critical you can't
do without them and certainly in Europe
we've learned that lesson and firstly we
need to look at what's available within
Europe I see in some countries including
my own there the mistaken idea that if
you leave it in the ground in Ireland
take it out of the ground some other
country imported into Ireland that you
actually helping to fight climate change
that's ludicrous other nonsense so we
need to have an overall framework for
Europe if raw materials are available
here we use them if they're not we
should look at where we can get them and
in that light
particularly free trade agreements have
an awful lot to offer we will be talking
shortly about Taiwan we've done a trade
deal with New Zealand which is very
welcome unfortunately the trade deal
with Australia fell apart that would
have been very helpful in giving us
critical raw materials like lithium so
we need to keep those going so that we
can diversify Supply utilize what we
have ourselves and then get more that we
need from other reliable sources
kutr thank you very much now we come to
the um final statements in our debate so
I begin to give the floor to
commissioner K
Bron
president
members Madam raor de Nicha let me thank
you first of all for today's uh debate
on this regulation on critical raw
materials I think we're sending out a
clear message that the EU is making
progress in uh reducing its strategic
dependencies now now we need to take
tangible steps to achieve this working
together with our
International Partners looking at how we
can make the most of the uh projects
that are developing on um in the
EU thanks to this regulation we now have
a framework in
place we can put the right
authorizations in place we've got all
the member states working together on
this problematic working together with
companies looking in at putting in place
uh monitoring systems dealing with uh
high-risk
situations we're working towards the
deadline of 2030 in the medium term we
have uh ambitious targets we have put in
place thanks to this regulation and
other accompanying measures I am sure
that we will make uh progress
immediately uh before concluding let me
just say the commission is committed to
putting out uh um uh a communication on
the review of the electric waste uh
directive now uh with this act on
critical raw materials we're moving
forward for uh green and digital
Transitions and strengthening Europe's
resilience thank you very much thank you
very much and now to conclude our debate
I give the floor to our reporter vice
president
n commissioner president colleagues for
all your contributions um your
participation in this debate is yet
another example of our shared ambition
on this very important topic and I say
it very clearly those who really take
the green and the digital transition
seriously has to vote Yes today on the
critical raw materials Act important
today's debate and vote are not the end
of the process they are only the
beginning the beginning of Europe's path
towards a secure and sustainable supply
of critical raw materials the European
Union must now translate the ambition
into concrete actions actions in the
member states and by the commission so
that quick permits became reality and
private investments in raw materials
projects will be facilitated actions
that make Europe a leader in the
development of substitute materials and
the implementation of innovative
processes and actions that deliver on
our our geopolitical Ambitions to be a
strategical sovereign union we need a
critical raw material agreement with
Australia Australia is a like-minded
partner and Ally for trade based on
values rules and Fair competition let us
seize the opportunity for free trade
between partners and close cooperation
on the raw material sector to strengthen
the role of value based cooperation in
today's geopolitically stormy landscape
we need to approach our Partnerships
with countries of the so-called Global
South by conveying clear messages we
want Partnerships on equal footing we
want local value creation we want mutual
benefits for all Partners involved we
want to do business with you let's use
the momentum we have created for more
raw material projects more Partnerships
and more and more Sovereign Europe This
law is only the beginning let us act
[Applause]
now thank you very much now this debate
is now closed uh